bonsoir à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france dont un vote
historique qui me fin on l'a vu donc à
un combat debout très longue haleine
bonsoir effectivement c'est un combat
qui sont menées les femmes seins
gentilles féministe ce argentine depuis
de longues années voire des décennies
pour avoir le droit à décider sur leur
propre corps mais comment c'est possible
que cette fois ci et son abouti dans il
ya le président monsieur fernandez qui
avait dit qu'il allait soutenir cette
proposition de loi et pendant sa
campagne présidentielle
les choses qu'il a fait aujourd'hui
d'après elahian deuxième point c'est la
ténacité des féministes des femmes''
argentine qui pendant des années et sans
lutter pour pouvoir voir la légalisation
de l'avortement mais aussi qu'il soit
gratuit ouvert à tous les femmes on a vu
qu'ils sont occupé tout l'espace
possible l'espace public les médias les
réseaux sociaux on les a vus débarquer
même ici au festival de cannes donc
qu'ils sont fait un travail de pédagogie
vraiment exemplaire et finalement ça
aboutit à qu'un certain nombre des
députés et des sénateurs ont revu sa
position face à l'avortement
puisque malgré en dépit de ses positions
et religieuses ses positions
philosophiques
ils sont décidés de approuvé cette loi
pour des raisons de santé des santé
publique puisque au milieu milliers de
femmes 1 argentine fait ses dessins
fortement clandestine donc aux
clandestins
d'accord c'est il ya des raisons aussi
de santé publique derrière cette
légalisation
alors c'est un profond changement pour
la société
argentine qu'est-ce qui va maintenant
comment ça va évoluer
c'est un changement pour la société
argentine mais ça peut donner aussi ça
ça peut donner l'exemple à d'autres pays
de l'amérique latine
il faut voir que le féminisme en
amérique latine et très protéiforme
d'un côté on a les féministes et des
communautés indigènes et indigènes les
féministes anti racistes des colonials
les féministes même pour un changement
du système capitaliste pour les droits
des minorités sexuelles donc skipper
l'exemple qui donne l'argentine après un
combat des années qu'il a menée c'est
des pouvoirs donnés aux féministes de
tout l'amérique latine la possibilité
dès que ses propres combats qui ne sont
pas forcément la légalisation de
l'avortement
sinon le droit aux terres les droits à
avoir les mêmes salaires entre hommes
ces femmes et c'est que ce combat puisse
voir la lumière dans les prochaines
années
on pense aussi par un simple au chili le
chili que va écrire pour la première
fois de l'histoire de l'humanité une
constitution paritaire moitié en moitié
femme donc on voit que l'amérique latine
la lutte féministe commence à gagner une
grande place dans l'espace de l'amérique
latine et est ce que c'est un camouflet
pour l'église catholique très influente
en amérique latine l'argentine qui le
pays d'origine du père françois barré
fectivement c'est un camouflet pour
l'église catholique parce que malgré que
en argentine et dans d'autres pays
l'église est séparé dé l'état l'église
continue a exercé une grande influence
sur certaines politiques
c'est surtout pas simple les politiques
d'avortement puisque l'amérique latine
c'est l'endroit au monde où c'est le
plus difficile qu'il femme puisse avoir
c'est donc effectivement c'est un
camouflé parce que les griffes
l'église catholique a perdu énormément
de terrain après tout les scandales de
pédophilie qu'il s'en sortir à la
lumière
donc effectivement malgré l' influence
du pape le papier argentin on voit
casser les mouvements sociaux que en
pris le dessus sur cette affaire alors
c'est une victoire pour les femmes
argentines toutes les femmes d'amérique
latine une victoire pour la société
argentine une victoire politique on en
parlait aussi pour le président de
centre gauche alberto fernandez qui a
beaucoup milité pour que ce projet
aboutisse
pour lui c'est une victoire politique il
va pouvoir surfer sur cette ferveur
désormais à son avantage
effectivement c'était une promesse de
campagne donc là la promesse a été tenue
et sûrement il faut voir que le
féminisme le mouvement féministe tout
autant en argentine qui est dans
d'autres pays comme le chili et le
brésil et commence à réunir énormément
monde donc les politiques et commencent
à se poser la question réellement des
voir comme des sa liste c'est aussi ces
chambres c'est la moitié de la
population c'est c'est des gens qui
votent et qui ne vont pas voter pour des
gens aux conservateurs ne vont pas voter
nous continuer à élire des gens qui ne
respecte pas ses propres soins elle soit
d d d avoir le droit à son propre corps
donc quand il ya un changement qui
commence à s'exercer en temps en argent
think et dans d'autres pays de
l'amérique latine
merci beaucoup à vous gabriela bravo
journaliste spécialiste de
amérique latine